[Music]
angelina jolie walks the red carpet at
the rome premiere of eternals with two
very special plus ones her daughters 16
year old zahara and 15 year old shiloh
[Applause]
the 46 year old actress holds hands with
her girls as they pose it up for photos
zahara rocked a long grecian style white
gown with a halter neckline that
featured gold straps and accessorized
with a pair of statement earrings while
shiloh wore a short sleeved black mini
dress with a thin leather bow complete
with a pair of bright yellow and black
high-top sneakers as for angie she
stunned in this silver versace
floor-length gown crafted from heritage
metal mesh along with a pair of
statement earrings of course this all
comes after angie brought her kiddos to
the hollywood premiere of the superhero
flick i'm a mom
so
that's my my thing angelina walked to
the red carpet with five of her six kids
zahara shiloh 20 year old maddox and 13
year old twins vivian and knox who all
wore vintage looks some straight out of
their famous mom's closet my kids are
all mixed with like vintage and my old
oscars these are my old oscar dress no
where where is she they just were
walking but they we did all vintage and
like upcycled my old stuff and while her
kids were by her side for the film's big
night she said they weren't exactly
thrilled about the gold spandex ensemble
she wears in the superhero flick and
would you want to see your mother
wearing that they were like
i don't know i think they're still they
haven't seen the movie so i think
they're gonna but i mean your mom walks
in in a full spandex gold outfit with
gold hair and you just think what do you
do for a living what are you
how do you get back in your robe but
wait because there's more
mother-daughter sweetness back in
september zahara joined her mom at
variety's power of women event in
beverly hills the two looked chic as
ever while posing for pics
the duo also stopped to take a photo
with honoree amanda gorman i had to
reread this six times angelina jolie is
presenting to you tonight i know i am
also flabbergasted with myself i think
she's such a fierce woman
i can't imagine anyone i'd be prouder to
be standing alongside tonight and when
angie took the stage to present the
inspiring young poet she called out
amanda's impressive qualities
the young woman of grace who stepped
fearlessly to the podium on inauguration
day
not just the youngest but the strongest
voice we could ask for in that moment we
need
voices like amanda's
those lights in the dark
so amanda
may you burn fiercely
and light the way for others so
naturally the question on all of our
minds could we see angelina and amanda
team up together in the future she's
such a strong humanitarian and that what
she stands for typically transcends the
entertainment industry so i'd love to do
something along those lines i know she's
very passionate about feminism education
so those are all my bread and butter